[Applause]
you guys i'm so excited to be here
uh i almost didn't make it though i was
at home watching my favorite show
16 i'm pregnant i love this show because
i love when bad things happen to bad
people
oh my god if you think your life sucks
watch this show you'll feel so much
better about yourself
because these girls are so you
just want to hit them you know whatever
i'm pregnant
whatever big deal i'm still going to
party this
then the moment they go into labor
they're like oh my god i'm like
it hurts right oh i hope you have twins
can't believe there's so much crap on tv
guys like i can't believe
the jersey shore is as big as it is like
my niece
tans all the time because of the show
let me say that again my mexican niece
tans all the time because of this show
like when you think about it tanning is
such a double standard because white
people can go and be dark for a week
i can't go anywhere enlighten i like
hearing white girls talk to their
friends hey girl you want to go tan
let's go be ethnic for a week
don't worry we're still white
it's a double standard white people you
have tanning boots there's no bleaching
booth for me
like hey i need to be two shades wider
this week i've got a job interview
[Music]
you guys ever lied so much on a resume
you're actually shocked that they give
you the job
like you lie so much you want to have a
talk with the company to make sure
they're not messing with you you know
like hey
come here are you sure about this
look at me look at my resume
do i look like an astronaut like when i
lie i go all the way i'm not gonna do
that whole hey
i type 80 words a minute i'm like screw
it i went to the moon
and i do that because my sister
is my fake boss for every fake job i've
ever had
so when you're calling to check
references you're never calling a real
company you're calling my sister's house
and you always know it's crap because
she's this like 40 year old mexican
mother of three so every time she
answers the phone she's like
hello
yes is nasa
yes with the chattels and the rockets
yes yes yes
yes said he'll get off the bed what
yeah she's the best astronaut that we've
got yes yes
she goes to the moon like five times a
week it's
get off crazy stupid bed right now oh no
i'm not busy no no
i'm in the middle of a countdown
10 9.
[Music]
here's the thing though guys as i'm
getting older i've realized that as a
latina there's certain activities i just
can't do
because i'm mexican and that struggle
you know like
a couple years ago i dated this white
guy on our fourth date he's like hey
this weekend
let's drive upstate we'll pick some
apples it'll be romantic
what say this weekend we'll drive
upstate we'll pick some apples it'll be
nice
no two white people picking apples
that's a romantic date
me i'm a migrant farm worker do you
understand that
like i would be afraid that they would
let him go but i'd have to stay to meet
my quota for the
i see you day dinner
[Applause]
i'm a tomboy i grew up a tomboy with
brothers you know i'm not a very
feminine girl which
is weird i can't pull it off that's why
i'm so jealous of girls that can do it
you know
you always see those girls dressed up
sexy on the weekends with their low-cut
blouses
it's like they're saying oh yeah
come and get it the worst is around
halloween because that's when they dress
up in those like costumes you
know
i'm a sexy french maid
[Music]
i can't do that i just look like a maid
that's the last thing i need is for me
to try to turn my boyfriend on and he's
like look who's doing some cleaning all
right
here's my laundry thank guys
thank you guys thank you
that's great great job really hilarious